me
sa cavale
[Musique]
non
boga sivori
d'où l'expression par la défaite
c'est ça mais est-ce que c'est crudo
c'est une omelette géante et j'ai envie
de te dire
hu
et
allo
services de la firme
non mais t'es sérieux
[Musique]
vidon ses toiles et maladroit n'est ce
pas eux avec ce 4e but
[Musique]
je suis super méga des zones et les
copains
[Musique]
on va pas se mouiller pour un devoir
simple et la carte nous devrions arriver
à une rivière
france
[Musique]
c'est comme une séance de musculation
pour les yeux à l'évoquer montre nous
voulons qu'ils nagent vite à lapins
n'ayez crainte pas trépident team
schtroumpfs
[Musique]
wallen travail
aucun sens nous
[Musique]
c'est quoi
les copains je suis vraiment mort de
secours
les schtroumpfs sont de retour préparez
vous un nouveau style ne dit pas des
choses bizarres c'est toi que blizzard
une nouvelle aventure
t'es sûr et un nouveau genre de straw
nous ne sommes plus au village des
schtroumpfs les schtroumpfs et le
village perdu alors le 5 avril la plus
belle aventure de la mènera de
l'intelligence après la carte nous
devrions arriver à une rivière va
falloir que tu t'entraînes le toit du
courage je vais tout faire exploser pour
nous verse en fait je suis là et
emmènera les schtroumpfs plus loin que
jamais est ce que c'est le village perdu
les schtroumpfs et le village perdu ils
n'ont pas vraiment l'air téméraire mais
c'est je trouve doivent accomplir une
mission si mystérieuse continuer si
périlleuse que s'en défient
l'entendement
le 5 avril découvrir un secret nous
avons découvert qu'une nouvelle forme de
vie plus grand que vous n'imaginiez
les schtroumpfs et le village perdu le 5
avril rome coche d'eau chauffage l'ex
football a droit et vous avez cru que
j'allais tomber dans le panneau
préparez vous un nouveau style et un
nouveau genre de stroom aux huîtres
copains à bray tempête les copains je
suis vraiment mort de ce truc
les schtroumpfs et le village perdu vous
en avez assez de livres dans un
champignon pas raison il m'arrive
d'avoir le blues être sûr protégé par
votre grand schtroumpf la forêt
interdite cette affaire dit vous êtes
privés de sortie
la grosse troupe joue les petits chez
vous le moment est peut être venu
d'essayer autre chose c'est fait
quelqu'un qui nous rassemblait ça
signifie peut-être que le village perdu
n'est pas une légende
il ya vraiment autres je trouve ton à
fort et nous devons les trouver on y va
tous ensemble et quand je dis ensemble
je veux dire tous les deux parias ses
dollars mais surtout toi et mme pourquoi
ne dit pas des choses bizarres
le 5 avril maladroit
et vous avez cru que j'allais tomber
dans le panneau découvrez un monde
secret d'une beauté incroyable c'est
comme une séance de musculation pour les
yeux remplis de créatures vous n'avez
vous retenir de manger de tout
approvisionnement l'autre est ce
vraiment étroit
nous ne sommes plus au village des
schtroumpfs
vous avez déjà vu quelque chose d'aussi
beau nous avons découvert une nouvelle
forme de vie des filles très intrigant
maisonnier pour vous mettre en garde les
chansons c'est gargamel
les filles moins de dépenses dit on
elles sont autoritaires les schtroumpfs
rires d'où l'expression par la maîtresse
je trouve ça lourd les schtroumpfs et le
village perdu je suis là chef des jetons
chez moi le choc des schtroumpfs je
trouve alors cause toujours pas piste
rouge nous connaissons tous ce village
aux maisons en forme de champignon où
chaque habitant
je vous demande pardon à son caractère
bien à lui créateur meilleur ennemi
angoissé de la vie vous savez parfois
j'ai le blues rouspéteur querelleurs
fouinât katia qu'est ce qu'ils font mais
ils ont une chose en commun genre ce
sont tous des garçons et maintenant
série de promotions un bois excepté l'un
d'entre eux la troupe est et s'il y
avait du nouveau
j'ai vu quelqu'un qui nous rassemblait
c'est impossible
et s'ils n'étaient pas ce qui a vraiment
d'autres troupes dans la forêt nous
devons aller trouver ça signifie
peut-être que le village perdu n'est pas
une légende
et là vous me parlez de cartes de choses
mystérieuses tiens qu'est ce qu'ils font
c'est pattison et offre une fleur bon
d'accord la droite et vous avez cru que
j'allais tomber dans le panneau
je suis pas très à l'aise dans le noir
j'ai déjà assez de problèmes en pleine
lumière je pensais pas que le village
perdu serait aussi difficile à trouver
quoi qu'il arrive surtout ne mangeait
pas toutes vos provisions j'ai mangé
toutes mes prévisions
est-ce que c'est plus dans nous ne
sommes plus au village des jeux trouve
ah ah ah
virage et se trouve perdu nous partons
exposition je leur ferai ils feront au
loup pcci je leur ferai et la prison que
mes provisions
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire tout
l'expression par la naissance nous
devons trouver ce village avoir un
rapace on offre
[Musique]
schtroumpf à l'eau on ne vous veux aucun
mal
on cherche le village perdu
de plus les copains je suis vraiment
modeste je trouve et le village perdu
dans le village des schtroumpfs
il y a des schtroumpfs qui jouent leur
rôle et il y a qu'ont fait ces
schtroumpfs la tâche tôt donc fallu net
je trouve maladroit koch est un peu gros
pour que je tombe dans le panneau
si les voir j'ai trouvé une carte qui
indique la grèce perdu mais on te fera
traverser la forêt interdite
ce serait pas la soirée interdite qui
grouille de d'anlier de se frise mortel
à chaque fois
[Musique]
l'année prochaine nous devons les
arrêter avant qu'ils ne découvrent la
vérité je la ferai où ils feront
contenant gargamel et là je ferai ma là
bas comment l'accusé
je vais bien enfin je crois quoi qu'il
arrive surtout ne mange pas toutes tes
ration croyez connaître les schtroumps
l'ensemble mes rations sont autant de
monde mais vous ne connaissez pas toute
l'histoire
qu'est ce qui se passe par là est ce que
ces deux villages perdus car t il son
arc
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent et si vous avez
la peau recouverte des camions et des
grues géantes
préparons nous à toute éventualité
non pas trop maintenant c'est sûr les
gars je suis en parler les schtroumpfs
et le village père d'amy
un nom m'a questionné dans quel talent
une envie de bouffer ses commentaires
chen aventure
suivez moi j'ai trouvé une tante qui
indique les villages perdus mais on te
fera traverser la forêt interdite
heureusement que moi je cours à côté la
terreur 1
comme on dit en français c'est une très
belle expérience
je m'éclate je m'amuse beaucoup je
prends beaucoup de plaisir à jouer cette
chan fait horreur et petra mrzyk oui oui
mais bien dit grand chose mais c'est
vrai qu'en plus là ça change tout ça
change tout ça doit être terrible
c'est un personnage que je connais
depuis des années des années aucun de
vous ne devra sortir de son champignon
sans me dire exactement où il va
vous avez raison cros trop longtemps on
m'a appelé le dans la vie au grand
schtroumpf
j'étais plus gérard j'ai tellement chou
vous croyez connaître les schtroumpfs
mais vous ne connaissez pas toute
l'histoire
qu'est ce qui se passe par là là je
trouve fait elle elle sait pas
réellement ce qu'elle est et donc du
coup elle a envie de savoir
et à part à l'aventuré pour pour savoir
tout ça on va découvrir des nouveaux
personnages et vous allez être surpris
préparons nous à toute éventualité
landes at-on sont très beaux dessins
animés des enfants ou s'ils ne
connaissent pas ils vont découvrir des
seins nus mais superbe parce que je sais
c'est tout ce roux maire au nom ma
question de sexe
m
[Musique]
après nice a aussi eu des génériques
sharon stone sour jones
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]